la délégation du conseil général de la
réunion dans les salons de boffrand à la
présidence du sénat le lieu est
prestigieux le prix également
les rubans du développement durable
depuis dix ans l'initiative lancée
notamment par l'association des maires
de france récompense des collectivités
locales pour leur engagement
cette année le département de la réunion
a été choisi comme une dizaine d'autres
collectivités
une reconnaissance nationale pour les
actions de développement durable dans
chacune des politiques du conseil
général les rubans du développement
durable est un prix nationalement connus
et qui est donnée par un jury autonome
le président est un philosophe et donc
je crois que c'est une récompense qui au
fond doit être dédiée à l'ensemble bien
évidemment des agents qui ont travaillé
au niveau du conseil général mais j'ai
envie de dire c'est le prix de chaque
réunionnais je dédie donc ce prix à tous
les réunionnais parce que nous sommes un
petit département l'éducation à la
culture environnementale à la culture
écologique et capital faut que nous
préservions et nous valorisons ce beau
patrimoine qui est le note qu'ils ont dû
classer au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
la majorité de ces jeunes nous les avons
mis sur des chantiers d'insertion en les
mettant en activité pour travailler dans
les hauts de l'île préserver l'existant
alors mieux qu'un discours je vous
invite tous vraiment à venir voir qu'est
ce que c'est que la durabilité chez nous
à l'île de la réunion
une invitation au voyage largement
applaudi parmi les invités au sénat qui
ont accueilli avec de larges sourires la
présentation faite par la délégation
réunionnaise dans la candidature le
département a mis en avant les efforts
portés sur le jardin de l'état ceux des
agriculteurs avec la diversification des
cultures l'artisanat avec la vinière
bois de goyavier et tous les projets en
faveur des eaux protéger le patrimoine
naturel en favorisant l'insertion
c'est l'un des aspects qui a séduit le
jury des actions à l'échelle locale
elles sont quasiment pratiquement les
seuls aujourd'hui
qu'ils prennent vraiment au sérieux
certains aspects de ce qu'on appelle la
durabilité pour la réunion c'est
l'histoire des sentiers et puis si vous
voulez le maillage environnement social
nouzha groupes intéressés oui ces
collectivités sont attentives aux enjeux
du monde au compteur contemporain oui
elles sont réactives aux attentes
nouvelles de leurs concitoyens le
président du sénat jean-pierre bel a
rappelé le rôle fondamental des
collectivités locales une politique sur
le long terme pour le conseil général de
la réunion avec les rubans du
développement durable c'est le troisième
prix que reçoit le département pour son
action dans le domaine